hallo und herzlich willkommen bei ZDF
heute live schön dass ihr dabei seid
heute geht es bei uns um den Krieg in
der Ukraine besser gesagt um bachmut das
ist eine der Kleinstädte im Osten der
Ukraine die seit Monaten im Mittelpunkt
der Gefechte stehen barmut wird aktuell
von beiden Seiten hart umkämpft und ein
Berater des ukrainischen Präsidenten
selenski hat schon gesagt diese Blut
diese Kämpfe sein einige der blutigsten
Kämpfe des gesamten Krieges ja die
Situation im Osten der Ukraine
entwickelt sich mehr und mehr zu einem
Zermürbungskrieg um bachmut und es
stellt sich die Frage kann die Ukraine
Putin aufhalten die russische Armee
versucht derzeit die ukrainische Armee
zum Rückzug aus der kleinen Stadt zu
zwingen aber auch die Ukraine versuchen
weiterhin den Vormarsch der russischen
Truppen zu stoppen lasst uns dazu mal
folgendes angucken
die ukrainische Armee hat gestern diese
drohnenbilder veröffentlicht darauf soll
einen Angriff auf eine russische
militärposition nahe der Front bei
bachmut zu sehen sein hier sei Munition
zerstört worden auch sei zu sehen wie
russische Soldaten nach der Explosion
aus dem Ort fliegen
ja wann entscheidet sich diese Schlacht
um bachmut welche Bedeutung hat diese
Kleinstadt aktuell wirklich und wie geht
es eigentlich den Menschen vor Ort
darüber möchte ich heute mit euch
sprechen aber nicht nur mit euch sondern
auch mit meiner Kollegin und ZDF
Reporterin Katrin Eigendorf in Kiew und
mit dem Militärhistoriker Professor Dr
Sönke Neitzel und ihr seid hier
natürlich auch mit diskutieren wie immer
eure Fragen an die beiden oder eure
Meinungen und Kommentare zum Thema könnt
ihr gerne hier in den youtube-chat in
den Facebook Chat oder per Mail an uns
an ZDF heute - live.at zdf.de schicken
jetzt spreche ich aber erstmal mit ZDF
Reporterin Katrin Eigendorf die uns live
aus Kiew zugeschaltet ist hallo Katrin
schön dass du bei uns bist
hallo guten Abend
Katrin du bist jetzt aktuell dort wo wir
dich sehen in Kiew war es dir aber vor
einigen Tagen in bachmut die Meinung
dazu wie wichtig diese stadtstrategisch
für beide Seiten ist die gehen ja
auseinander wie schätzt du denn die
Wichtigkeit dieser Stadt für beide
Seiten ein und warum wird gerade sie so
stark umkämpft
ja bachmut ist ja schon seit langer Zeit
eine strategisch wichtige Stadt für
beide Seiten weil wir die Stadt
kontrolliert der hat den Zugang zu der
Republik Don jetzt und das war ja immer
das Ziel der russischen Armee auch in
dem Moment als sie im Sommer die den den
anderen Teil des dornbasen nämlich
lukans kontrolliert haben überbachmut
praktisch auch die komplette Kontrolle
über den weiteren Teil des Don Bass zu
erlangen aber wenn man sich die
Situation heute dort ansieht ist es
eigentlich vor allem eine symbolische
Schlacht also es geht darum wer schafft
es jetzt wirklich letztendlich die
Kontrolle über bachmut zu verschaffen da
geht's gar nicht mehr so sehr um
strategische Fragen und das ist für die
russische Seite sehr wichtig weil es
gibt ja im Prinzip
innerhalb der russischen Militärs große
Probleme und die wagnergruppe die im
Prinzip als Söldnergruppe dort aktiv ist
möchte in bachmut dem Militär vorführen
wie sie dort erfolgreich im Prinzip
kämpfen kann und das erreichen kann was
die russischen Militärs dort nicht
geschafft haben also das ist deswegen
strategisch für die russische Seite und
für die ukrainische Seite hat es auch
einen großen strategischen also
symbolischen Wert weil bachmut immer
wieder im Zentrum eben diese
Aufmerksamkeit ist geht wer schafft es
jetzt wirklich hier die Kontrolle zu
halten aber es hat auch immer wieder
Momente gegeben wo die ukraineische
Regierung auch gesagt hat sie denkt
darüber nach bachmut aufzugeben weil im
Prinzip wenn man sich das vorstellt
steht in dieser Stadt kaum noch ein
Stein auf dem anderen ist sind nur noch
wenig Leute da zurückgeblieben
eigentlich nur noch ja alte kranke und
Familien die dort diese Stadt aus
sozialen Gründen nicht mehr verlassen
konnten und die Leben unter ständigem
Beschuss also das ist eine total
unerträgliche Situation für die
Zivilisten die dort zurückgeblieben sind
wir als Journalisten können in die Stadt
gar nicht mehr rein weil das teilweise
dort auch zu so brutalen Kämpfen kommt
das ist für uns viel zu gefährlich ist
ich war jetzt in der Nähe von bachmut
und habe da mit ukrainischen Militärs
gedreht die russische Stellungen mit
deutschen Panzerhaubitzen angreifen und
habe darüber eine Geschichte gemacht
aber selber in die Stadt reingehen ist
für Journalisten im Moment extremst
gefährlich und davon rede auch die
ukrainische Regierung rät auch das
Militär ab
ja da sehen wir ja auch gerade die
Bilder wie du bei bachmut bist und diese
Soldaten begleitet die dort eine
deutsche Panzerhaubitze im Einsatz haben
wie hat denn diese deutsche
Panzerhaubitze den Kampf dort für die
ukrainischen Soldaten geprägt und wie
geht es den Soldaten aktuell dort wie
gut können sie sich aktuell verteidigen
also die Soldaten mit denen wir
gesprochen haben haben uns erzählt dass
für Sie wachmut in diesem Krieg wirklich
der gefährlichste und schlimmste Ort ist
den sie erlebt haben und die Stellung
die wir da besucht haben da war es so
dass wir dort uns nur 20 Minuten
aufhalten konnten weil die Soldaten
haben gesagt dass sie jederzeit damit
rechnen dass eben auch die russische
Seite sie wiederum beschießt wenn Sie
diese beschießt und deswegen die Leben
dort schon auch in großer Sorge aber
deutsche Waffen also diese
Panzerhaubitzen haben schon für die
Ukraine einen großen Unterschied in
diesem Krieg gemacht weil das versetzt
Sie in die Möglichkeit eben auch die
andere Seite anzugreifen aus Entfernung
das ist ja der wichtige Punkt aber was
mir die Soldaten auch erzählt haben was
ich ganz interessant fand dass diese
Panzer auchitzen so dauerhaft und
ständig im Einsatz sind dass sie immer
wieder kaputt gehen und sie sie
reparieren müssen aber dass sie eben
Deutschland sehr sehr dankbar sind dass
sie dieses Material zur Verfügung
bekommen haben und dass sie auch die
Ausbildung dafür zur Verfügung bekommen
haben weil es ihnen wirklich ermöglicht
diese Stellungen dort zu halten
du warst ja nicht nur in bachmut was für
ein paar Tagen auch in der 35 Kilometer
entfernten Stadt Krammer Thors und hast
dort mit Menschen live vor Ort
gesprochen da sehen wir jetzt gerade
noch mal an der Karte also bachmut liegt
wirklich direkt auf der Frontlinie und
kann man Torf ungefähr 35 km entfernt
dort leben also Menschen noch ganz
normal so normal das möglich ist
gestalten irgendwie Leben lass uns mal
einen Blick auf dein Stück werfen und
schauen wie es den Menschen dort vor Ort
geht die direkt an der Front leben
müssen
der Weg nach gramatosk führt durch ein
zerstörtes Land nichts ist hier
geblieben die Häuser unbewohnbar
verlassen
auf dem kleinen Wochenmarkt von
kremators ist Angst und Sorge spürbar
die heftig umkämpfte Stadt bachmut ist
nur 35 km entfernt von hier
das ist ganz bei uns in der Nähe noch
ein bisschen und dann ist das alles bei
uns deshalb besorgt uns diese Situation
sehr
du legst dich schlafen mit Angst du
wachst damit auf ohne Ende Angriffe das
alles macht Angst
von 1,210000 Einwohner sind 70.000
geblieben es sind vor allem die älteren
und die Armen die nicht gehen können
oder nicht gehen wollen in einem
Luftschutzkeller treffen wir Alexander
und scharenko es ist kalt im Keller
Heizungen Strom fallen ständig aus immer
wieder musste auch der Bürgermeister bei
Angriffen im Feldbett übernachten
sollte wochenweise wochenlang dann wird
es schwierig zu überleben also das heißt
die zentrale Heizung fällt sofort auf
also man kann zwei drei Tage das kann
man schon
heizen aber länger dauert es nicht auf
dem plosch hat Mira dem Platz des
Friedens wirkt krematorsk wie eine
Geisterstadt verlassene Geschäfte
verlassene Straßen Gräben sollen Schutz
bieten bei Luftangriffen auch an diesem
Morgen schrillen die Sirenen
nur wenig wurde zerstört in krematorsk
in den elf Monaten Krieg die russische
Armee konnte bislang hierhin nicht
vordringen doch am Bahnhof erinnert ein
Mann mal an einen der brutalsten
Angriffe die Stofftiere gehörten den
sieben Kindern die hier am 8 April von
russischen Raketen getötet wurden als
sie mit ihren Familien auf den
evakuierungszug warteten der sie in
Sicherheit bringen sollte
ja das sind wirklich wahnsinnig
eindrückliche Bilder hast du mit den
Menschen vor Ort auch über die westliche
Militärhilfe gesprochen die ja kommen
soll es sollen Kampfpanzer geliefert
werden wie ist die Stimmung dazu hofft
man noch darauf oder hat man das Gefühl
dass er eigentlich schon zu spät
nein die Menschen in grammatos setzen
ihre ganze Hoffnung darauf dass der
Westen ihr Land unterstützt nicht nur
militärisch also es ist auf der einen
Seite natürlich die große Sorge dass sie
sagen dass ihre Soldaten wenn sie nicht
vernünftig ausgerüstet sind mit mit
schlagkräftigen Waffen einfach ja
wegsterben schneller als als noch
Nachschub zu besorgen ist aber auf der
anderen Seite ist es nicht nur das
militärische was die Leute besorgt
sondern es ist auch die soziale Frage
also viele Menschen mit denen wir in
kammertours gesprochen haben haben
gesagt dauerhaft können Sie in dieser
Stadt gar nicht mehr leben weil die
gesamte Infrastruktur ist zerstört es
gibt ja auch dort gar keine Betriebe
mehr die funktionieren also sie sind von
humanitärer Hilfe auch abhängig und ähm
knüpfen natürlich dauerhaft ihre
Hoffnung darauf dass der Westen sie auch
in der Hinsicht unterstützt also da hat
man sehr differenziertes Bild auf das
was vom Besten zu leisten ist und ich
glaube
ähm ja man muss nicht immer den Blick
nur so sehr auf das militärische
fokussieren das ist ein Aspekt der Hilfe
die die Ukraine erwarten aber diesen
Krieg werden sie das verstehen Sie
sicherlich nicht so schnell gewinnen
können und in der Zeit müssen natürlich
die Menschen auch irgendwie weiter leben
überleben
ich habe hier noch eine letzte Frage aus
der Community an Dich Kathrin und zwar
fragt Youtube Userin Mary daily 08 wie
ist die Einschätzung von Katrin
Eugendorf Zurückeroberung bachmuts danke
an Katrin Eugendorf für die exzellente
Berichterstattung
also ich sehe die Perspektive im Moment
so dass ich keine so große Chance sehe
bachmut zurück zu erobern ich denke
irgendwann stellt sich für die Ukraine
auch die Frage wie viel Menschen will
sie in wie viel Menschen leben will sie
da opfern um die Kontrolle über eine
Stadt zu bekommen die im Prinzip in
Schutt und Asche liegt und wo kaum noch
ein Stein auf dem anderen steht und ich
habe ja auch mit dem Bürgermeister von
kremators gesprochen und er sagt dass
eine große Sorge auch der Militärs ist
dass wenn Sie diese Orte sowie bachmut
aufgeben dass dort einfach noch zu viele
Zivilisten sind und dass die sich
teilweise auch nicht evakuieren lassen
das stellt die Militärs vor große
Probleme aber meine Perspektive ist der
Krieg ist im Moment an einem Punkt den
auch die ukrainische Regierung ja als
Tiefpunkt bezeichnet russland versucht
im Moment wirklich mit einer Offensive
an allen Orten anzugreifen also ich habe
das selber in den zwischen 14 Tagen
erlebt wir waren an so vielen Orten wo
wir immer ganz ganz nah bei uns
plötzlich Angriffe erlebt haben das habe
ich wirklich in dem ganzen letzten Jahr
dieses Krieges in so einem massiver Form
nicht erlebt also
bachmut wird irgendwann ja im Prinzip
vor der Frage wird man vor der Frage
stehen lohnt es sich da die Kräfte jetzt
zu binden weil dieser Krieg wird von
Russland wirklich massiv im Moment
eskaliert
na ähnlich sieht das auch ein YouTube
User der uns gerade zuschaut Ralf Thomas
Niemeyer sagt bachmut ist es nicht wert
noch mehr Ukrainer zu opfern aber das
ist auch die Politik des Westens danke
Katrin für deine Eindrücke vor Ort alles
Gute
ja und jetzt wollen wir den Blick noch
mal so ein bisschen weiten und darüber
sprechen wie sich dieser Stellungskrieg
im Osten der Ukraine entwickeln könnte
und welche Rolle die westliche
Militärhilfe spielen könnte und das
besprechen wir jetzt mit dem
Militärhistoriker Prof dr Sönke Neitzel
hallo Herr Neitzel schön dass Sie bei
uns sind
hallo solltet ihr da draußen Fragen
haben an Herrn Neitzel oder eure Meinung
zum Thema mit uns teilen wollen dann tut
das gerne hier im YouTube oder Facebook
Chat oder per Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zdft.de
seit Monaten wird bachmut wirklich hart
umkämpft welche strategische Bedeutung
hat diese Stadt in ihren Augen
also wir müssen glaube ich uns
vergewärtigen dass die Ukraine in
bachmut eine relativ gute ausgebaute
Verteidigungsstellung haben sie haben da
die Möglichkeit seinen taktisch relativ
lange gegen die Russen zu kämpfen und
wenn sie backen aufgeben würden
ist die nächste Verteidigungslinie
hinterbach mit einem sehr schwierigen
sehr offenen Gelände also die Gründe
warum die Ukraine so daran festhalten
ist eben auch die Frage wenn wir
wachmund aufgeben
das haben wir eben in den Beitrag auch
gehört ist dann möglicherweise das ganze
doch was geht dann verloren was kommt
danach in Städten die wachmut kann man
den russenhof Verluste zufügen das haben
alle anderen Schlachten schon gezeigt
und man hat einfach aufgrund der
geographischen Lage in Bach und die
besten Möglichkeiten sich zu verteilen
und das ist ein Grund warum die Ukraine
so daran festhalten es wird jetzt auch
so ein bisschen was haben sie ja schon
angedeutet in ihrem Beitrag symbolische
Frage weil selenski war da
es wäre ein Schlag für die Ukraine wenn
Sie das aufgeben müssen nur wir müssen
uns auch vergegenwärtigen wenn bachmut
fällt geht der kriegt natürlich in der
gleichen Intensität 10 km westlich
weiter also es ist einfach eine
Situation wenn die Ukraine unter großen
Druck ist und deswegen dann auch da
kommen sicherlich noch zu über die
Waffenlieferung so wichtig sind
ja sie haben es gerade schon
angesprochen Bewegung gibt es da gerade
relativ wenig können nicht können wir da
gerade die Entwicklung eines quasi
militärischen Pass beobachten und wo
könnte das auf Dauer dann hinführen und
passend dazu fragt auch einen User wann
fängt man endlich an zu verhandeln immer
mehr Waffen zu schicken ist keine Lösung
ja fangen wir mal mit der User Frage an
also natürlich glaube ich dass hinter
den Kulissen versucht wird Möglichkeiten
auszuloten
Spielräume auszuloten für Verhandlungen
nur das passiert natürlich nicht im
offenen also der deutsche Botschafter in
Moskau von Geier natürlich jetzt nicht
im ZDF live erklären was also gerade vor
hat und das ist natürlich
Geheimnisse nicht betreiben und ich
hätte großes Vertrauen ins Auswärtige
Amt auch ins Auswärtige Amt anderer
Staaten dass sie nicht in der Nase
bohren sondern dass sie natürlich
versuchen Dinge auszuloten Dinge möglich
zu machen das Problem ist nur
das Kriege in der Regel eben nicht am
Verhandlungstisch entschieden werden
sondern auf dem Schlachtfeld und so
schrecklich das für uns Deutsche
erscheinen mag und solange beide Seiten
glauben sie haben militärisch noch eine
Option
wird der Krieg auf dem Schlachtfeld
weitergehen und
meines Erachtens natürlich gar nicht
genau sagen es ist jetzt gessing ist
Putin der Ansicht nach der Mobilisierung
im Herbst letzten Jahres steht ja auch
wesentlich breiteren Füßen militärisch
die russischen Streitkräfte haben sich
erheblich vermehrt und ich meine
argumentieren zu können das Putin glaubt
um längeren Hebel zu sein also gut dann
aber keinen Grund in Verhandlungen zu
gehen weil er glaubt
über die Zeit heraus
eine bessere ein besseres Platz zu haben
als die Ukraine und die Ukraine hofft
natürlich auch westliche Waffenlieferung
das sieht das auswirkt also diese
deutsche Haltung die aus der Jose
hervorgeht dieser Stimme kriegt möge
eigentlich Enden das ist sehr
verständlich aber ähm das ist meines
Erachtens nicht die Logik Putins und
logischerweise auch nicht die Ukraine
die natürlich sagt ja Enden natürlich
bald
aber wir wurden gerne dass die Russe
unser Land verlassen und wir haben es
auch einen Beitrag gesehen momentan
kämpft man ums Überleben und da ist die
die Vorstellung ein Kompromiss zu
schließen gerade wenn wir die
Kriegsverbrechen vom Mut und so sehen
nicht wirklich sehr attraktiv
wir haben ja passend zu dem Thema auch
noch eine Meinung aus der Community und
zwar sagt Bora B auf Youtube selensky
hätte in Washington nicht über Bach Mut
sprechen dürfen das war ein großer
Fehler danach hat sich Putin entschieden
die Stadt dem Erdboden gleich zu machen
Thema militärische Unterstützung aus dem
Westen da haben wir ja jetzt sehr lange
drüber gesprochen berichtet jetzt ist ja
die Entscheidung für die Lieferung der
Kampfpanzer da können die jetzt gerade
in dieser Situation noch Veränderung
bringen oder kommen die dann auch so ein
bisschen zu spät weil es dauert ja so
noch vier ich meine eher acht Wochen bis
zur Auslieferung
ja also vor Ende März werden die
sicherlich nicht an der Front sein wie
sich diese kampfpanzerlieferung konkret
auswirken werden ja das können wir heute
eigentlich noch sehr schwer abschätzen
nicht über diesen Krieg vor allen Dingen
nichts wissen das müssen wir noch mal
ganz deutlich an der Stelle sagen wie
alle
diskutieren natürlich darum und man kann
in den Medien hier sehen wir alle
versuchen uns eine Meinung zu bilden wir
wissen die wir nicht jetzt sagen in
militärischer Funktionen sind über den
kriegst sehr wenig aber selbst die
Bundeswehr weiß über die Lage der
Ukraine sehr sehr wenig sehr
zurückhaltend
so damit ist diese Frage für mich schwer
zu beantworten aber ich fange jetzt mal
an das ein bisschen zu ordnen also
es wird gesprochen über die Lieferung
letztlich von knapp 100 Leopard 2
Panzern die Ukraine haben zu diesem
Zeitpunkt heute und jetzt in diesem
Moment etwa 6 bis 800 Panzer die sie
einsetzen Unterstützung ihrer Infanterie
wir haben bisher keine großen Panzer
Gefechte gesehen und die Frage ist wird
sich das ändern wird also diese Leopard
Panzer anders eingesetzt als die
ukrainischen Panzer etwa für eine
ukrainische Gegend Offensive das wissen
wir nicht das kann nur der ukrainische
generalstoff
beurteilen das ist hängt sehr davon ab
wie die Ukraine diese Panzer einsetzen
das ist von ganz vielen Faktoren
abhängig
ich also das ist ein offener Fragen ich
glaube nicht dass 90 Kampfpanzer diesen
diesem Krieg eine wesentliche Änderung
verpassen werden für eine große
Gegenoffensive sind meines Erachtens die
Ukrainer noch zu schwach
weil die großen mobil gemacht haben und
unter diesem Aspekt
ist das was sie eben sagen too late to
little vielleicht dann vielleicht zu
treffen weil im September letzten Jahres
als die Fronten Bewegung war als die
Ukraine der Gegend Offensive gestartet
haben hätten diese Panzer sicherlich
noch einen Unterschied machen können ob
sie das jetzt können
werden wir sehen es ist auf jeden Fall
eine Stärkung der ukrainischen
Verteidigungsfähigkeit aber ob sie
wirklich dazu beitragen können jetzt
bald den Krieg zu sein das müssen wir
abwarten und dann würde ich zumindest
mit Bleistift an Fragezeichen
auf jeden Fall eine Unterstützung der
Ukraine ist auch ein politisches Zeichen
vielleicht ist das politische Zeichen
Richtung Moskau noch wichtiger als das
meditiert
wir haben hier chronologisch quasi noch
eine Frage vor den Waffenlieferungen aus
der Community an sie und zwar vom
YouTube User der Zeitgeist der fragt
speziell an sie hernalze sehen Sie die
Gefahr eines Zusammenbruchs der
ukrainischen Verteidigung noch bevor die
neuen Lieferungen von Panzern und
Schützenpanzern ankommen
also ich würde mal Rätselraten mehr kann
ich leider auch nicht machen und sagen
nein das sehe ich nicht ich glaube schon
dass die Ukraine auf einem relativ
soliden Fundament steht und ähm wir
müssen es leider so sagen also die die
die Ukraine haben ja fast 900.000 Mann
mobilisiert ähm so schlimm diese Kämpfe
in bachmund sind so schlimm das Sterben
das ist das wird der Ukraine meines
Erachtens nicht das Rücken sondern da
sind wir glaube ich schon in einer
längeren Zeitung bezahlt
das Problem ist dass der ukrainische
Generalstab extrem zurückhaltend mit
Herausgabe von Informationen ist und
zwar auch an die NATO auch an die
Bundeswehr die wissen natürlich mehr als
ich jetzt aber insgesamt können wir ganz
ganz schwer einschätzen wie eigentlich
wirklich die Lage auf der ukrainischen
Seite ist der Westen hat es seine
Nachrichtendienste mehr Informationen
über die Russland über die Ukraine und
diese Frage
erreicht die Ukraine möglicherweise so
ein Break Even Point wo die ukrainische
Armee zusammenbricht ähm ist für uns
unglaublich schwer zu beantworten meine
Vermutung wäre dass die Ukraine nicht am
Ende ihrer Möglichkeiten ist sie hat
eine sehr hohe Kampfmoral sie können ähm
sehr viel improvisieren sie haben Kampf
Erfahrung gehabt und die Verluste sind
noch nicht so hoch dass die Ukraine
jetzt dass sie unzählige Zusammenhalt
verlieren würde und jetzt
zusammenbrechen würde das noch nicht
aber die die Frage ist natürlich schon
irgendwann kommt nächster Punkt wann
dieser Punkt kommt können wir als als
Drucker sowieso nicht nicht voraussehen
aber natürlich kommt dieser Punkt dann
würde auch irgendwann in Russland kommen
wann diese Punkte erreicht sind ob die
in einem halben Jahr erreicht sind in
zwei Jahren oder wann auch immer können
wir nicht voraussehen und wir können
eigentlich nur von Woche zu Woche
beobachten was dort passiert und mein
Argument wäre den muss man nicht
zustimmen um ein Argument wäre der
besten sollte sich ein bisschen spucken
die Ukraine so zu unterstützen damit es
dem ukrainische Staat auch in Zukunft
weiterhin noch gibt
ja passt vielleicht gerade ganz gut
jetzt ist ja für Freitag diese Woche
auch ein EU-Gipfeltreffen in Kiew
angesagt was sind denn die Erwartungen
wenn man auf dieses Treffen guckt sie
Lenski spricht ja zumindest mal er
erwartet Zitat Neuigkeiten
ja also natürlich ungeduldig und wir
haben ja gesehen als die Entscheidung
verkündet wurde zu liefern hat dann ein
wenig ich glaube am gleichen Tag sogar
noch ähm Flugzeuge und auch 35 und
U-Boote gefordert also natürlich in der
Situation wir haben es auch in den
Beitrag gehört wenn man an der Front ist
wenn man das Sterben sieht erwartet die
Ukraine hofft die Ukraine vielleicht die
bessere Formulierung auch westliche
Unterstützung auch noch mehr westliche
Unterstützung ich glaube dass dieser
Gipfel der EU Gipfel vor einigen
politisches Signal ist also Signal und
das ist immer man vielleicht auch eine
Hoffnung damit ein Frieden zu erreichen
der Westen wird die Ukraine weiter
unterstützt dann wird sie so
unterstützen dass Putin mit
militärischen Mitteln der Ukraine
sein will nicht aufzwingen kann die
Message du wirst diesen Krieg du bist
eine Krieg den nicht erreichen wir
stehen hinter der Ukraine
und das ist glaube ich ein wichtiges
Signal da müssten auch entsprechende
Handlungen folgen das passiert ja im
Rahmen der Möglichkeiten jetzt mit dem
Panzerlieferungen und es wird
wahrscheinlich auch nicht bei den 94
bleiben
aber ich
könnte mal über die die Kampfflugzeuge
vielleicht sprechen aber ich glaube dass
die EU auch gut daran tut sozusagen eine
gewisse Vorsicht warten zu lassen immer
zu fragen was ist militärisch wirklich
notwendig was können wir liefern wie
können wir den Krieg auch nicht weiter
eskalieren
und das das selenski deine andere Logik
hat ist klar aber die westlichen Staaten
haben eben auch ihre eigene und wollen
natürlich auch nicht sich direkt an
diesem Krieg beteiligen und insofern
wird es wahrscheinlich dabei bleiben
und man wird sehen was jetzt da ein Tier
verkündet wird also wirkliche
bahnbrechen Neuigkeiten kann ich mir
eigentlich nicht vorstellen
Thema Eskalation dazu gibt es auch eine
Frage aus der Community und zwar vom
YouTube User gerade Vortex der fragt wie
weit sollen Waffenlieferungen gehen bis
zum Eintritt der NATO weil das wird
passieren jetzt hat ja
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck vor kurzer
Zeit gesagt es werden keine Kampfjets
geliefert was kann da jetzt noch
passieren wie sieht es aus mit weiterem
Waffenlieferungen im Bündnis
also die klaren roten Linien sind meines
Erachtens die die Entsendung von Truppen
denn mit der Entsendung von Soldaten
wenn man kriegsverteil völkerrechtlich
ich kann ich kann keine Stimme in der
NATO das fordert und ich sehe auch keine
politische Stimme die das fordert und
das ist also glaube ich es ist dann
wirklich die rote Linie alles andere
ist würde ich mal englisch sagen also
die Frage ist natürlich die man stellen
kann zurecht sind
und da würde ich ein bisschen Ordnung
ins Chaos bringen die Ukraine hat ja
eine Luftwaffe von etwa 150 Kampf
Flugzeugen und sie hat etwa 50 davon
verloren
und natürlich wird die Berlin westlichen
Staaten irgendwann diese Verlust
ersetzen müssen sonst gibt es keine
ukrainische Luftwaffe mehr und der
Luftkrieg ist vielleicht nicht
entscheiden in diesem Krieg aber spielt
eben doch eine nicht zu
vernachlässigende Rolle also wenn man
will dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg
überlebt dann muss sie irgendwie einen
Luftwaffe haben um sich zumindest zu
verteidigen zumindest eine kleine
das wird nach meiner
Wahrnehmung darauf hinauslaufen dass
Polen mit 29 Jäger
irgendwann dann doch an die Ukraine
liefern und selbst die werden irgendwann
kaputt sein oder abgeschossen sein
und das ist dann wahrscheinlich der Fall
an dem westliche Staaten möglicherweise
F16 Jagdflugzeuge liefern aber immer
noch in dem Ziel sein diese relativ
kleinen Leben zu haben etwas anderes ist
es was er selenski gefordert eigentlich
eine völlig neue ukrainische bauen die
selber auch nach Russland wirken kann
und z.B auf die russischen Flughäfen
Angreifen von denen russische
Kampfflugzeuge aufsteigen und ähm Kiew
oder andere Städte mit Langstrecken
beschissen wenn man das will ist das
eine völlig andere Dimension und das
wäre dann wirklich eine Eskalation weil
dann muss die Ukraine in die Lage
versetzt werden ein Luft kriegt nach
Russland zu tragen und das kann sie
eigentlich nicht ohne aktive westliche
Hilfe also diese beiden Dinge würde ich
unterscheiden diese Lieferungen der mit
29 werden wahrscheinlich kommen um
überhaupt die Ukraine weiter in die Lage
zu versetzen in der Dimension Luft sich
weiter zu verteidigen
lassen Sie uns jetzt zum Schluss noch
mal einen Blick nach Russland werfen
morgen ist ja an historisch bedeutsamer
Tag die Schlacht um das ehemalige
Stalingrad jetzt sich zum 80 Mal und der
russische Präsident Putin wird im
heutigen Wolgograd eine Rede halten was
erwartet man von dieser Rede
ja das Problem ist dass wir Putin nicht
im Kopf schauen können und dass wir
eigentlich mit vielen Voraussagen falsch
schlagen wir haben ja auch gedacht dass
am 9 mai also den Tag des Sieges über
das nationalsoistische Deutschland jetzt
vielleicht die mobil machen verkündet
wird und sie wurde am 9 mai so nicht
verkündet bisher waren eigentlich die
Voraussagen
für diesen historischen Jahrestag
eigentlich immer falsch und daher würde
ich aber warten dass er eine Rede in dem
üblichen Ductus hält dass er versucht
eine Parallele zu ziehen vom großen
Krieg das zweite Weltkrieges der
Verteidigung in das Deutsche Reich und
seine Verbündeten zu heute dass er
wieder versucht gegen die Nazis in kieft
die vermeintlichen Anführungsstrichen zu
wecken und das er versucht eine
parallele herzustellen
weil er weiß dass damals im Zweiten
Weltkrieg die Völker das Sowjetunion
vielleicht gar nicht so für den
Kommunismus oder die Regierung sondern
vor allem für ihre Dörfer für ihre
Heimat bekämpft haben und das ist da
eine unglaubliche ein unglaubliche
Motivation gab sich zu Wert zu setzen
und erfüllt glaube ich dass ihm die
Zustimmung auch in der long run einfach
wegbricht deswegen wird er immer wieder
versuchen mit die Geschichte als
Argument die Geschichte als Waffe zu
verwenden sehr viel mehr
Eskalation der Kriegsführung oder
dergleichen also mehr als Worte kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen ich weiß es
natürlich nicht wir müssen uns alle
überraschen lassen aber ich würde sagen
Parallelen ziehen zusammen Auftritt auf
dem roten Platz am 9 Moskau also was
ähnliches würde ich da aber
ja wir sind gespannt auf diese Rede
morgen hernalzel danke dass sie sich
meinen und diesen Fragen aus der
Community angenommen haben danke schön
ich werfe zum Schluss unserer Sendung
noch mal einen Blick in die Kommentare
und in die Stimmung bei euch und da
schreibt zum Beispiel auf Youtube der
User Jumpy im Krieg ist die Moral
wichtig deshalb ist bachmut so wichtig
wenn bachmut aufgegeben wird dann
passiert das selber an anderen Orten und
Sabine bromack sagt auf Facebook ich
hoffe die Ukraine bekommt alle Waffen
die sie braucht wenn Putin Sieg wird das
furchtbarer Auswirkungen haben weltweit
ja ein
Zermürbungskrieg rund um bachmut mit
einem scheinbar Stillstand wie das
weitergeht wir bleiben auf jeden Fall
für euch dran ich sage ganz herzliches
Danke für Eure Kommentare und Fragen zu
dieser Sendung und wir sehen uns wieder
bei ZDF heute live in ihr mögt